sometimes the truth comes from the most
surprising places
look what just fell out of the mouth of
an old socialist in a recent interview
Bernie Sanders said the Democrats
selecting Joe Biden as a nominee will be
making the same blunder they did with
Hillary remember she lost then blamed
the Russians and wandered in the woods
for a month Bernie bashed three of
Biden's stances that he shared with
Hillary that he voted for NAFTA and
permanent normalized trade relations
with China and the war in Iraq these
positions say Bernie won't rally young
people working people or people of color
so Bernie's saying that the winning
candidate should be against NAFTA be
against normalized trade with China and
the war in Iraq if that's the case
Bernie just adores Trump for a second
term it's amazing I mean I get it Bernie
thought he was talking about himself
since most people aren't but in staking
out that turf he just admitted he wants
what Trump said he wants now Bernie in
case you're napping Trump already blew
up NAFTA he's challenged China and he's
denounced recent Foreign Wars sure
Bernie may be casting himself as the
outsider looking to unseat the
establishment but he's way too late the
establishment is the pack of left-wing
libs worshipping at the feet of a OSI
and the New York Times editorial board
the real outsider right now is already
in the White House it's kind of obvious
what's next for Bernie
maybe terrorizing the Brits laughing off
the EU and making fun of Jeremy Corbyn I
have a plan that should save him some
time money and effort just endorsed
Trump drop out buy another house or one
you have to admit I like that one but
don't you see the overlap the overlap
Sanders in Trump our agree on more
things and they disagree poor now I said
before I think that Bernie supporters
and Trump supporters are mirror images
yes just that you know you could you
come to this point in the populist
middle and suddenly you say oh no I fall
with ya Bernie because I believe in so
many of the leftist thing or I fall with
Trump on the right side right that lines
right there
yeah what's interesting to me is that I
think you look at the polls there's a
new CNN poll out today you see that
Biden is maintaining either mid
to low 30s let's say what you see from
Bernie is he's fading a little bit yeah
and so I think this is his strategy get
back in the game
Ocasio Cortez last week said with regard
to climate change oh you know what you
can't just do middle ground and beat
Trump you can't go back to the
establishment the old game and here's
Bernie coming out saying much the same
thing that he's establishment if you
think that he's exciting or energetic
you're wrong you're just repeating
Hillary yeah you know it's interesting
to to remind us Dana because we were you
know obviously critical of Trump
precisely for the things that Bernie was
kind of talking about what's really we
didn't you know I
we're free traders right I mean they did
so yeah so you can see that where you
for example Bernie would say we would
never do anything to touch entitlement
spending yeah I'm never gonna do that
and we're gonna get rid trade and then
you could see where there were some
people like I think that there are some
Democrats those people like in Michigan
Wisconsin and Pennsylvania who voted for
Obama but then voted for Trump yes I
think that was because if the candidate
had been Bernie Sanders not Hillary they
might have actually voted for Bernie do
you see what I mean yes following
closely so I listened to something today
that I have to recommend oh but listen
at 1.5 speeds because my driver crazy so
the New York Times has a podcast called
the argument and they take an issue and
then they debate both sides and you can
decide on your own how you feel about it
but today's was about socialism versus
liberalism okay so it was but it was the
intra mural fight with it yes a party
what was interesting to me is the guy
that was representing socialists he is
the managing editor of Jacobin magazine
he basically said we think Bernie we're
gonna get them all the way up there and
then of course we know we probably won't
win so we're just hoping that then they
will just support Biden in the yeah it's
like all of this is for what exactly
what is it for Emily what is like about
why are we here at the moment our
entertainment I think that the Democrats
obviously think Biden is going to win
they think he's the one that can beat
and that's their bottom line that's
their bottom wish but I think that's why
Bernie his biggest challenge is
convincing them that he too can beat
Trump or he would be the one to beat
Trump and he's not willing however to
sacrifice his ideas his far-left idea
to get there so those in the middle
won't necessarily back him and Biden's
biggest challenge at this point is
convincing voters that he's not just
Hillary 2.0 although he's come a little
bit farther than she in that regard and
so basically both of them are trying to
convince voters they're like the whole
package but I think Biden's in it for
the long con and Bernie is only focused
on the primary at this point and by the
way I think his climate change package
today was him trying to say to the far
left no I hear you I'm not
middle-of-the-road hey AOC listen to
this policy I'm there right there with
you but this is how it's going to work
you know Lawrence I think that they have
the problem is is like Biden overall is
probably a better package but Bernie's
the more interesting package and has the
more energy he has the more energy and
he's also the one that's willing to make
sweeping changes yeah the problem as a
former Obama voter the problem that I
see with the bitee loader for Obama
[Laughter]
where's my G no for the minute right the
message of that they're destroying
everything they're there they're tearing
up the country apart we want to go back
to the founding documents what bernie is
doing is then the identity politics
aspect there so although he wants
sweeping changes he demonizes people on
a day to day basis and those are those
Obama voters that he could pick up but
he's already missed out an opportunity
right there because he continues saying
those people are the problem not
Washington is just the problem those
people are the problem and so if you
want to get those people you got to
reach out to those people he's not
willing to compromise on that so you got
Biden who's the same old same old guy
you're Bernie that wants to make
sweeping changes but the voters that
they need he's not willing to grab by
the way you know what it strikes me as
I'm listening to you is that so much of
Biden support comes from black voters
it's overwhelming well well until the
new general election well we don't
tick-tock about the crime bill they're
tired of
yes they're very upset about I don't
have eggs and and I'm not saying that
they're gonna vote for the Republicans
but it will depress the vote and they
will stay home well that's possible but
to me let's get the next election but
it's interesting I don't think that
Sanders has done well with black voters
Lawrence and I think that he needs to
anybody needs to who's wants to overtake
Biden does the black support for Biden
stay in place one final note the fight
between Bernie and Joe Biden's going to
get uglier and worse this month as we
approach the first debates because
that's where they got to take down Biden
and bite into this big lead yeah you
know what and I've just said on to
fighting's credit you know what was in
his green new deal well you know what
you know what maybe tomorrow but now
it'll be old by then G is never old that
is true